Mais grandir avec des livres tout autour de soi
avec des gens pour parler de ces livres,
ce n'était pas des choses apprises à la légère.
A 18 ans, j'avais une profonde passion pour les livres.
Ce n'était pas la seule passion que j'avais.
Je suis un Indien du Sud
élevé au Bengale.
Et voilà deux choses concernant le Bengale:
ils aiment leurs plats salés
et ils aiment leurs sucreries.
Alors quand j'ai grandi,
encore une fois, j'avais une passion bien établie pour la nourriture.
J'ai grandi à la fin des années 60 et au début des années 70,
et il y avait un nombre d'autres passions auxquelles je m'intéressais
mais ces deux-là étaient celles qui me différenciaient.
(Rires)
La vie était alors belle, épatante.
Tout allait bien
jusqu'à ce que j'ai environ 26 ans,
et que j'aille voir un film appelé "Court-Circuit".
Oh, certains d'entre vous l'ont vu.
Et apparemment, il est en train d'être refait en ce moment
et il va sortir l'année prochaine.
C'est l'histoire d'un robot expérimental
qui est électrocuté et prend vie.
Et quand il fonctionnait, cette chose disait "donnez moi des données. Donnez moi des données".
Et j'ai subitement réalisé que pour un robot
les informations et la nourriture,
c'était la même chose.
L'énergie lui venait sous une forme,
les données lui venaient sous une forme.
Et j'ai commencé à me dire
je me demande comment ça serait
de commencer à m'imaginer
comme si l'énergie et les informations étaient les deux choses que j'avais comme données,
comme si la nourriture et les informations étaient similaires par la forme.
J'ai commencé à faire des recherches à cette époque, ça m'a pris 25 ans,
et j'ai découvert
que les êtres humains, en tant que primates,
ont des estomacs bien plus petits
qu'ils ne devraient l'être étant donné notre poids
et des cerveaux bien plus gros.
Et en poursuivant mes recherches,
je suis arrivé au point où j'ai découvert quelque chose
qu'on appelle l'hypothèse des tissus onéreux.
En fait, pour une masse corporelle donnée d'un primate
le taux métabolique restait stable.
Ce qui changeait était l'équilibre des tissus disponibles.
Et deux des tissus les plsu onéreux dans notre corps
sont les tissus nerveux et digestifs.
Ce qui s'est dégagé c'est que des gens ont avancé l'hypothèse
qui est ressortie avec des résultats fabuleux vers 1995.
C'est une femme qui s'appelle Leslie Aiello.
Et l'article suggère alors que vous avez échangé l'un pour l'autre.
Si vous vouliez que votre cerveau soit gros par rapport à une certaine masse corporelle,
vous deviez vivre avec un intestin plus petit.
Ca m'a alors complètement poussé
à dire, ok, ces deux choses sont connectées.
J'ai donc regardé la culture de l'information comme si c'était de la nourriture
et j'ai dit, nous étions donc des chasseurs-cueilleurs d'informations.
Puis nous sommes devenus des fermiers et des cultivateurs d'informations.
Est-ce que ça explique vraiment ce que nous voyons
avec les batailles de propriété intellectuelle actuelles?
Parce que ces gens qui étaient des chasseurs-cueilleurs à l'origine
voulaient être libres, errer et cueillir l'information comme ils voulaient,
et ceux qui étaient dans la culture de l'information
voulaient construire des clôtures autour,
créer la propriété, la richesse, la structure et le règlement.
Il y aurait donc toujours des tensions à travers cela.
Et tout ce que j'ai vu dans la culture
disait qu'il y avait eu des combats énormes chez les gastronomes
entre les cultivateurs et les chasseurs-cueilleurs.
Et cela se passe ici.
Quand je suis passé à la préparation, la même chose était vraie
excepté qu'il y avait deux écoles.
Un groupe de gens disait que vous pouvez distiller vos informations,
vous pouvez en extraire la valeur, la séparer et la servir
alors que l'autre groupe changeait d'avis
et disait, non, non, vous pouvez la faire fermenter.
Vous la rassemblez et vous la broyez
et la valeur émerge de cette façon.
La même chose est encore vraie avec l'information.
Mais la consommation est le point où ça a commencé à devenir vraiment amusant.
Parce que ce que j'ai alors commencé à voir
c'est que les gens ont tant de manières différentes de la consommer.
Ils l'achetaient dans un magasin en tant qu'ingrédients bruts.
Vous le cuisinez ? Est ce que vous vous le faites servir ?
Est ce que vous allez au restaurant ?
La même chose est vraie à chaque fois que je commençais à penser à l'information.
Les similitudes devenaient folles,
cette information avait des dates de péremption,
les gens utilisaient mal les informations qui n'étaient pas datées correctement
et cela pouvait réellement affecter les marchés financiers,
les valeurs des sociétés, etc.
Et à ce moment-là j'étais devenu accro.
Et j'étais dans ce processus depuis environ 23 ans.
Et j'ai commencé à réfléchir à moi-même
comme nous commençons à avoir des mashups de faits et de fictions,
des docu-fictions, des faux documentaires, appelez ça comme vous voulez.
Allons-nous atteindre le moment
où l'information a un pourcentage de faits qui lui est associé ?
Nous commençons à considérer l'information selon le pourcentage de faits ?
Allons-nous commencer à regarder ce qui se passe
quand notre source d'information se tarit, comme une famine ?
Ce qui m'amène au dernier point.
Clay Shirky a un jour dit que la surcharge d'informations n'existe pas,
il y a seulement une défaillance du filtre.
Je vous dit que l'information,
si on la ramène à la nourriture,
n'a jamais de problème de production; on ne parle jamais de surcharge de nourriture.
En gros, c'est un problème de consommation.
Et nous devons commencer à penser
à la manière dont nous créons des régimes, des exercices en nous
pour avoir la possibilité de pouvoir gérer l'information,
pour avoir la possibilité d'être capable de le faire de manière responsable.
En fait, quand j'ai vu "Supersize Me" j'ai commencé à penser à dire
Que se passerait-il
si un individu regardait Fox News pendant 31 jours non-stop?
(Rires)
Y aurait-il le temps d'être en mesure de travailler avec ça?
Vous commencez donc vraiment à comprendre
que vous pouvez avoir des maladies, des toxines, un besoin d'équilibrer votre alimentation,
et une fois que vous commencez à regarder, et de là,
tout ce que j'ai fait en termes de consommation d'informations,
la production d'informations, la préparation d''informations,
je l'ai regardé du point de vue de la nourriture.
Ça n'a probablement pas aidé mon tour de taille
parce que j'aime m’entraîner des deux côtés.
Mais j'aimerais vous laisser avec juste cette question :
si vous commenciez à regarder toutes les informations que vous consommez
de la manière dont vous pensez à la nourriture,
que feriez-vous différemment?
Merci beaucoup pour votre attention.
(Applaudissements)